with an estimated 1.3 million ukrainian
canadians rallies like this one in
niagara falls are meant to raise
awareness of tensions in ukraine many
demonstrators fear for their relatives
in their homeland there's no happiness
there's no joy
because you have this ominous army on
the on the borders nato is still sorting
out what to do about those 100 000
russian troops at the border making it
clear there are limits to its
involvement in the event of an invasion
we have no plans to deploy nato combat
troops to ukraine uh
nato allies have trainers there we help
them from nato with
building capacity modernizing their
defenses including their cyber defenses
the military response is not guaranteed
because ukraine is not a member of nato
the ukrainian national federation of
canada says signaling restraint makes
sense saying you know there's going to
be no nato
forces in ukraine
may be a good thing to be saying today
but uh you know once the fern first
russian bomb lands or maybe when the
first tank comes in
you know that may be an opportunity to
change a position canada is not a
central player in world politics but the
government is making moves global
affairs canada confirming it's
temporarily pulling out non-essential
staff from the canadian embassy to
ukraine and defense minister anita anand
has arrived in kiev to meet with
canadian forces personnel deployed there
and with her ukrainian counterpart
ukrainian-canadian leaders are asking
all canadians to express support for the
cause through their members of
parliament they're also raising money
for a humanitarian campaign in case it's
needed in the event of an invasion and
bloodshed
ross lord global news
across ukraine soldiers have been handed
their deployment notices and citizens
including thousands of women are joining
the call to arms our europe bureau chief
crystal gumansing is in kiev tonight
two sergeants both under 30 about to be
deployed to ukraine's conflict zone in
the eastern border region known as
donbass
canadian soldiers from operation unifier
helped train the rapid response brigade
members global news met up with the
soldiers at a military museum
raptor that's his call sign says this
will be his fourth deployment in the
region where the ukrainian military has
battled russian-backed separatist
factions since 2014.
he explains at first his parents and
brother worried about him but he says
now it's harder for his parents his
brother is being deployed with him in
maverick again we've agreed to use their
call signs instead of their names says
he's ready this is his first deployment
he's trained but says he knows he can't
prepare for everything
far from any battle lines these women in
kiev are also bracing for a worst-case
scenario they aren't soldiers but they
want to know how to fend for themselves
and their families if civil unrest hits
close to home i was really scared i had
bad sleep at night and i was thinking
about that i need to develop plan a plan
b and plan c and we all know from the
history of the recent conflict that most
civilians actually die than combatants
so i think it's essential you know at
least to know some basics i remember the
situation in 2015 for instance i also
had an emergency back i had a newborn
and had an emergency back
and i was really scared but
now my husband is going to join tertiary
defense
and i'm go i'm going to to have this
training and i'm going to find more
information and to be more prepared the
workshop's leader alexander beletsky
says canadians helped develop the course
the key thing that people should
collaborate because it's much easier to
survive together in the groups and to
survive as a family as a person the
sergeants praised the women for learning
skills to protect themselves and
possibly their country
if it comes to that
crystal gomansing global news
keeve